un caso que está lejos de resolverse los
interrogantes acerca del asesinato de la
periodista palestino estadounidense y
reina booklet continúan luego de que
estados unidos ratificara que su
investigación fue realizada por un
comité de expertos independientes
el coordinador de seguridad llegó a la
conclusión de que los disparos
efectuados desde una posición de las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes fueron
probablemente responsables de la muerte
chilinga bucle y coordinador de
seguridad tampoco encontró motivos para
creer que se tratara de un asesinato
intencionada
mientras desde israel ratificaron esta
versión y dijeron que continuarían las
investigaciones sobre la bala que acabó
con la vida de la reportera desde el
medio al yazira que trabajaba agua que
subrayaron que hay otras pruebas
provenientes de otras investigaciones
que apuntan directamente a israel
me gustaría señalar que la bala no es la
única prueba hay otras pruebas testigos
en lugar de las heridas los restos de
las balas también las investigaciones
que se realizaron todas ellas condenan a
israel en este crimen y el intento de
eeuu demostrar que israel es inocente ha
fracasado
desde el 11 de mayo el día en que la
periodista perdió la vida tras una
incursión de las fuerzas israelíes en
una urbe de la cisjordania ocupada las
hipótesis sobre lo ocurrido han sido
múltiples y desde todos los flancos
afectados al yazira anunció que llevará
el caso al tribunal de la haya palestina
investigó de manera independiente e
incluso la onu se pronunció y
constatamos que los disparos a boat ley
procedieron de las fuerzas de seguridad
israelíes no de disparos indiscriminados
de palestinos armados a la espera de más
evidencias el asesinato de la reportera
sigue generando tensión entre israel y
palestina cuyas relaciones están
deterioradas tras una escalada general
de violencia